welcome to this video infernal exam XM
GM 2 533 from Russia and pave pankratov
rated 260 for many strong GM's around ok
I'm playing the French oui novel which I
this is an old favorite of mine this
line I recently played it in the some
open tournament in Austria that I
managed to to win at the end this liner
had played but my opponent hadn't even
played Queens you form the idea of this
line is to quickly exchanged the bishops
like that Bishop to a 6 and then try to
use the dark squares the problem is that
the screen g4 a maneuver led to this
weakening of the of the Kings side and
he's got night to g3 to h5 attacking
here and this is them I'm them the
problem for black there are many
positive things about this and this
opening like the light square has and so
on but the porn here this is a big issue
ok let's reroute the night
hmm
yes my ideas and if he takes it i just
play book age 7 and I'm saying okay you
got this but if you move the light I'll
take h4 and there's still the weaknesses
here so go into f3 to see have some
direct way to attack okay let's go Quinn
c4 and c5 getting getting counter plane
I don't turn exactly have a good king
and it's not it's not attacked at the
moment but interesting should I go see
my idea was see 6b five night be six
actually but maybe he's just doubling
okay but doubling on the a file is not
so inspiring for what I can still play
c5 complicated position it feels like
white should be better but it's not not
easy if i take now he's probably playing
probably playing Queen age three yes ok
so I have to take it
well this isn't completely easy it looks
strange from a look strange for me i
know but i have this counter play him I
want to go Knight b6 use the airport
maybe he can play ok one him he doesn't
need to take of course
ok won him many oh I didn't see that at
all what is the idea maybe you just
wants to push the f porn ok I have no no
big cam choice need to get ahead here
now I've nite nite see for coming
wow this so terrible already here okay
wants to take and claim that this is
sound this is a winning a check okay can
i can take with the Queen
not even i'm not even sure that okay
let's say i need to do to play something
i have come to play with the 8th porn
anyway winning the rookwood nice but
even this isn't so so on so bad
he six yeah one move tricks one move
tricks everything else Greek yeah I
should have seen this of course yeah 26
is God Bishop d6
yeah II 6mm I don't know what the
position was so if I don't blunder this
I really cannot cannot this cannot
assess it yeah the snow just falls apart
of course
can I castle no half move the rock like
10 times yeah he's got rock v8 just just
crap him black reason yeah it was it was
I still think a very interesting
position before I blunder this move like
rook be six or something is just an
interesting position or like this just I
wondered what the heck is Queen g3 doing
at threatening e6 okay now this is just
unclear I don't know I have half the
queenside maybe I could have could have
taken the rook this is a possibility or
here maybe there were what chances now
but it is very very risky to take it
attacking the rook something like that
is very very risky of course
very complicated stuff yeah it was a
very interesting game I'm only a bit bit
annoyed that I gave it away with the one
with blunder maybe maybe instead here
instead of this I should have considered
g6 I know it looks a bit if here
allowing that but it takes time and I
have to the counter play here if it
keeps if it gets closer I can also move
the king it's a completely unclear
position I think I don't know what's
going on okay interesting fired thanks
for watching